[Music]
hollow tube just Louis and my friends
this is guns on here welcome to my sixty
second episode of dirty chest tricks in
this episode I am going to show you two
high profile monty silly trick in the
queen's indian defense from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following model d fall here it doesn't
matter whichever more order of black
prefers let's say in this game a six has
been played first and after c for black
indeed played Knight to f6
now many white player don't like the
Moon Knight to c3 as they have to face
the names of Indian defense so what they
come up is the second alternative namely
Knight to f3
okay we have the Queen's Indian defense
on the ball with the trademark move b6
and after some critical moves g3 Bishop
to b7 and Bishop to g2 as you can see
Black has mainly two good options to
develop in the dark square bishop
first let's check out Bishop to b4 check
which is also known as BOGO Indian
variation and against this why should
continue with Bishop to d2
well in recent times Black has tried
various options such as fi as well as
Queen to e7
however bishop to d2 is still one of the
popular choice the point is after Queen
captures d2 castle and Knight to c3 the
obvious logical responses Knight to e4
counter attacking the white queen
get ready guys because here comes the
movement with Setzer the nice tricky
platform for our upcoming monty silly
trap and that is Quinn - see - attacking
the knight Black has few options
number one defy is pretty bad move
because that will completely lock down
this light square bishop and so as fi as
after this move white can simply respond
with Knight to e5 and result shows that
the spin is quite annoying and black
lost some horrible games from this
position so to cut the long story short
here if you check this position in
online database then you will find out
that night capture c3 has been highest
Lee played mu in this position and it's
logical as well because after this not
only black is get reading of this one of
the night but he's no longer in the pin
of this lovely diagonal and yes indeed
if white continue with the routine moves
such as Quinn capture c3 then the
resulting position are looking quite
good for the black cam but there is a
big-time trick exist in this position as
black get losing position after white
just one move can you see it
yep Knight to g5 and suddenly it is now
black who get the rude shock number one
what is threatening a checkmate on at
seven and the number two the bad news
for the black camp is that this bishop
has been unleashed on b7 saw that now
black cannot defend both of this thing
black and try to options but none of
them are working
the first move I want to consider is
Queen captures GFI well after that the
task is very easy yup you capture on b7
black can throw this in between moves
such as night captures e - but what is
not in a rush to capture that rook
so Queen captures e - is the obvious
response
after the following forcing sequence
Knight to c6 Bishop captures a 8lu
captures age the old moon disposition is
to save this pawn with the Queen moves
however with the modern engine y can
play this accurate move rook to d1 and
if you carefully look at this position
white obtained an exchange which in a
long run with the accurate play a
completely winning advantage for the
white camp
well black can play Queen check and grab
a to pawn but I don't think so it's
going to walk out and I have attached a
sample game in the PGN where analysis
clearly shows that white full point
cannot be denied
okay what happens if black continue with
Knight to e4 well more or less same
story as we are going to continue with
Bishop captures evil and our threats are
remain as it is black cannot save his
bishop for example if he continued with
either the moves c6 or defy then that
doesn't stop why as what has this
wonderful tactic Bishop captures defy
and black will still lose the rook in
the corner
so that's right out of the equation the
best response for the black is to
capture this bishop but after Bishop
takes Queen takes as the mating threat
is as it is black has no time to save
the rook so accordingly Queen captures
defies the only logical response but we
transpose more or less to the same
position after Queen captures rook
Knight to c6 Queen to b7 and Knight
captures deform where again black is an
exchange down but this time around he
has some counterplay
now in order to understand how good this
position is for the wide I like to show
you a game where a grandmaster crushed a
2,200 plus rated opponent within few
moves from this position
white played our trademark new look to
Devin saw that if any checks happen then
he can safely play King to have fun okay
black responded with direct threat Queen
to e5 trying to checkmate the white III
counter attacking the knight Knight to
see to check King to e2 and I think
black was desperate in this position so
he continued with Queen captures b2
thinking that I'm an exchange down but I
have two extra pawn and white King is
quite open but just one
Roop to d2
and suddenly black realize that he is in
a big trouble
he tried Quinn to see three unpinning
the night but after White's next reply
look to see one it is confirmed that
black is going to lose a piece quincy
for King to d1 and game continues for a
few more moves but one can safely see
that once white munch this piece then
black defeat cannot be denied
well the proper Queen's Indian moves
Bishop to d7 and amazingly enough even I
found a line which create a similar tree
against this variation
here a wide shoot castle first and after
black castles the most popular choice
from the white side is to play Knight to
c3
however rope to even sets up the same
cunning tactical pattern
well by far one of the most popular
choice by black is to play d6 and
liberating the other knowledge and only
now we are going to continue it Knight
to c3 so as you can see if allowed then
we wants to play d4 so natural enough
most of the black player has continued
with Knight to e4 thinking that since
there is no Queen to c2 so we are
completely fine except one thing that
again they have fallen into the upgrade
version of the Monticello trap
can you guess why it's next reply
Congress solutions if you see this super
surprising move Knight to g5 boom well
all of this trick has the same platform
namely this poor pinning knight black
has two good options over here but
amongst them if we continue with night
cap to c3 then this is a pretty bad move
at first sight it looks tremendous
but if you recall of a last trick you
will easily find whites next reply yup
Queen to c2 not only hitting the maid
but hitting the b7 bishop and after the
following sequence Bishop captures G Phi
Bishop captures b7 Knight captures e to
check rook takes Bishop captures even
Bishop captures 8th Bishop to at 6 and
Bishop to g2 the dust is clear and
clearly this time around black doesn't
have single counter play for his loss of
an exchange
the batter move in this position is
Bishop captures g5
however white still get the winning
position with Bishop captures g5
again night capture c3 fails because of
the following sequence Bishop captures
d8 night capture Stephen Bishop captures
b7 rope kept his d8 rook captures demon
Knight to d7 Bishop captures a8 and rook
after the eight at the end of the
sequence what is a clear exchange of
without any porn loss so this is even
worse for the black cap
that means Queen captures Jafar is a
forced response and after that we can go
ahead with night captures evil
if the Queen moves then we have night
check and then winning the bishop as
well as rook in the corner so by force
black has to take this night and after
that we will continue with Bishop
captures evil attacking the rook in the
corner
well few games in this position continue
with defy which I think a big-time
positional blunder has after pawn takes
pawn takes and the simple Bishop to g2
left black with a backward C pawn which
can be easily targeted and look at this
wonderful diagonal all together white is
in a completely driver seat
so no that's not the right option the
correct move in this position is c6
planning to play the d5
okay no issues we are going to continue
with Twain to d3 counter-attacking
that 7-pole
again Black has two choices if we defend
on at 7:00 with g6 then after the
following continuation F 427 and Bishop
to g2 and the next turn we will take the
whole center with evil and just look at
the spin because of it there is a
traffic jam scenario on the black side
and altogether black get a completely
cramped position but you may ask hang on
at this position black doesn't need to
defend on at 7 but he can counter attack
with defy so the idea is very obvious if
white continue with Bishop captures at 7
then after King to achieved this Bishop
doesn't have any retrieve Square and in
the next turn black can play the mover
fire and trapped on this bishop so isn't
that a blunder by white
well guess what here comes the last
trick on the table White has
deliberately played this model because
he wants to play this cunning move Queen
to a3 counter-attacking the black rogue
so black needs to defend this with
Knight to d7 and now that star Bishop
comes back in a star with Bishop to d3
and at the end of the sequence white
emerge with an extra pawn and a better
position
you
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this - wonderful monty silly trick
in the Quinns indian defense remember
invite your opponent to put this night
on this juicy Foursquare so that you can
unleash some of the cool tricks as I
have shown in this video well thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment and I will
meet you in my next episode very soon
bye and take care